THE MOST PRECIOUS THING IN THE
WORLD
IS THE FINANCIAL SECURITY
AND WELL-BEING OF YOUR FAMILY.
YOU WANNA SEND YOUR LITTLE
ONES TO THE BEST SCHOOLS,
AND IN THE END,
KNOW THAT YOU'VE LEFT
THEM WITH PEACE OF MIND.
NOWADAYS WE ALL KNOW THAT CASH
RULES EVERYTHING AROUND US:
CREAM, GET THE MONEY,
DOLLAR-DOLLAR BILL, Y'ALL.
THAT'S WHY IT'S TIME TO ENTER
THE 36 CHAMBERS.
COME STEP TO THE "WU",
WU-TANG FINANCIAL.
AT WU-TANG FINANCIAL,
WE'LL WORK WITH YOU
TO DEVISE THE BEST PLAN
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAM.
I MEAN, SMITH BARNEY--
BUNCH OF BITCHES.
OLD-TIME FARTS.
YOU GOTTA KNOW HOW
TO JACK THIS (BLEEP).
YOU GOTTA PLAY
THIS GAME ROUGH.
IN, OUT, GET,
GRAB, BONK.
YOU NEED TO DIVERSIFY
YOUR BONDS, NIGGA.
MILITARY
IS BLOWIN' UP.
WE ABOUT TO GO TO WAR,
INVEST IN SOME NUCLEAR BOMBS.
THIS AIN'T
TRADING PLACES, NIGGA.
THIS IS REAL
(BLEEP) LIFE !
PROTECT YOUR GODDAMN
NECK, A'IGHT ?
WU-TANG FINANCIAL,
A PLACE FOR YOU AND YOUR KIDS.
ALL OF OUR TRUSTED CONSULTANTS
ARE HERE TO MEET YOUR NEEDS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE OL' DIRTY
BASTARD COULDN'T MAKE IT TODAY,
BUT HE SENDS HIS REGARDS:
DOO-DA-DOO-DA-DOO-DA.
SO CALL US,
BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY,
WU-TANG CLAN AIN'T
NOTHIN' TO (BLEEP) WITH.
♪ WU-TANG CLAN AIN'T
NOTHIN' TO (BLEEP) WITH ♪
♪ WU-TANG CLAN
AIN'T NOTHIN' TO (BLEEP) WITH ♪
♪ WU-TANG CLAN AIN'T
NOTHIN' TO (BLEEP) WITH ♪
♪ WU-TANG CLAN
AIN'T NOTHIN' TO (BLEEP) WITH ♪♪
STEP TO THE "WU",
WU-TANG FINANCIAL.